guess what's here guys the samsung
galaxy z
fold i gotta be careful with this knife
i don't even think i'm gonna need a
knife to be honest with you
i'll put it away
[Music]
i'm really excited about this phone
because i never got a chance to check
out the first
samsung fold i've been watching all the
press announcements and i've been
following along the rumors for quite
some time
but now it is sitting on my desk change
the shape of the future introducing
galaxy z
fold to 5g reimagine the possibilities
i'm so excited about this like i'm very
very very very very excited to get my
little mitts on this thing
and it's the mystic bronze thank you to
samsung for sending me a review unit to
check out
can't wait to check this out i'm
checking it out look at me i'm checking
it out
so here's all the care instructions do
not press on the screen or the front
camera lens with a hard sharp object
okay when folding the device make sure
there's no objects inside of it
not dust or waterproof do not remove the
screen protector film your device
contains magnets this does have a
protective screen on it they said if you
do want to remove the screen that you
should have it professionally removed at
a samsung store or some
other third party retailer this is the
moment
[Music]
[Applause]
look at it look at it
they do have several different hinge
colors so if you do want to customize
this
that is also something that you guys can
do i'm very glad that this has just the
all mystic bronze hinge
it looks awesome it's a very nice fold
that's nice so here it is unfolded and
then here it is folded
it is it's pretty thick i'm curious to
see what this looks like in comparison
to
the note 20. so it basically is
two note 20s kind of stuck together so
what's cool is this does have a front
screen and then the inside is also all
of the screen
but look at this color sorry i have
already smudged it up with my smudgy
little fingers
but it really does look awesome like
this is such a great color one of my
favorite phones this past year
has been the galaxy z flip it's just so
freaking cool and i think what they did
with this is they took
some of the design elements of this
hinge and implemented it into
the new z-fold 2. this has been such a
great phone like i absolutely love it
like this is just
such a cool device i wonder if i'm at my
200 000 flips yet
yeah justine can't come to the phone
you're gonna have to try have to try her
other phone
hello also inside the box we have our
fast charger
usbc cable sim card ejector quick start
guide
this isn't the 5g flip this is the
previous one from earlier this year but
this has still been one of my favorite
phones
so i'm very excited to test this out i
feel like this is the best of both
worlds between the z
flip meets the note 20. so before we
turn this on let's take a look at some
of the features main display is 7.6
amoled while the cover is 6.2 this front
cover is victus gorilla glass while the
back is gorilla glass 6.
you can see the factory installed screen
protector right here and it is
recommended to not try to remove this
yourself
like all new phones the samsung has been
coming out with this is 5g it also has a
qualcomm snapdragon 865 plus processor
you can choose from 128 or 256 gigs of
storage
it has 12 gigs of ram and a 4500
milliamp battery it comes in two colors
mystic bronze and black
with four variations of hinge colors
metallic silver metallic red
metallic blue and metallic gold this
doesn't shoot 8k or the ultra high res
photos like the note 20 but it does
still have single take
pro mode adaptive auto framing and flex
mode
i love flex mode on the z flip so i'm
really glad to see that also carrying
over to the fold the fingerprint sensor
is located right here on the side power
button
it has a triple camera set up here on
the back with the main camera which is a
12 megapixel f 1.8
a 12 megapixel f 2.2 ultra wide camera
and a 12 megapixel 2.4 telephoto with 2x
optical zoom there's two identical
selfie cameras here
on the front cover and on the back cover
these are both 10 megapixel f 2.2 i love
that you can run multiple apps at once
on the same screen using the
multi-active window you just drag and
drop up to three apps into place you can
also use this divider
to change your screen size
this is cool because it does have
wireless charging so you can charge it
right here on the back so when i watched
a bunch of people's videos
of the first version of this a lot of
people kept commenting like i can see
the crease i can see the fold
which yes in video you really can see it
so it's interesting because when you are
actually holding it like this
you don't notice it as much and that was
something that i got
very used to when i was using the z-flip
so i feel like now that i've kind of
been accustomed to that style of screen
all the improvements that they have made
since the first generation they've used
that to their advantage to make this one
even better
i accept all of your terms and
conditions do what you want
what you want with my z flip z fold i
mean
oh my gosh how many times have i called
this z-flip do i call this a z-flip yet
i'm not sure either if this was any
bigger i don't think i would be able to
hold it like this
so it is it's actually quite perfect if
i fold it just a little
oh that's nice well then you can see the
crease okay i can see it more from this
angle
if i'm looking at it like this you can
kind of see it i mean if you fold it you
can
of course you're going to see it i also
should probably download some games
from game pass because gaming on this
thing i bet is going to be
really really cool i'm going to try
playing xbox game pass
on this device for the first time ever
so this is going to be coming out very
shortly here but i'm testing out the
beta version of this we set up a top
down
so that's why things may look a little
bit different but let's cut to
the top down shot i have an xbox elite
controller
connected to the z fold
we're gonna play a game i'm gonna turn
up the volume guys this is
these speakers are ridiculous
[Applause]
i am hitting absolutely everything
driving in the ice is a challenge
[Applause]
all right that's absolutely amazing what
else can
we see of thieves so again this is beta
this will be out very soon
it's just so exciting like i actually
i'm getting a little emotional right now
like freaking halo oh my god playing
hillary we're playing caleb
let's do it let's do it i can't believe
this
you guys i know i've already told you
what i'm doing but i just need to
reiterate the fact that i'm playing halo
on my phone
this is a 2020 redeeming factor
there's a lot of blood on the ground
some apps don't
support resizing while they're running
these apps will restart okay let's do it
oh my gosh this is crazy okay you can
also play on the cover screen so i just
restarted it
and now i'm playing on the cover screen
circle west and check it out
oh it told me not to telegraph my
presence and i was shooting them sorry
i was telegraphing no believer i'm
seeing heat six
[Applause]
look at that front screen okay this
looks really
good look at that ah it's so cool
it's great because you do have a front
facing or back facing camera
depending upon how you're holding this
and this is probably one of my favorite
features
i haven't tried it yet but i saw it in
the demo you will be able to see
yourself
in the front screen cover
screen preview tyler there you are i'm
gonna take your picture are you ready
it told me to clean my lens i'm filthy
it just used the gesture and it
automatically took that picture that
it's still taking pictures like you're
doing that
here's our setup we've got a light we've
got another camera that's our podcast
set up
oh that hurts so bad
anyway i'm gonna pick this back up and
act like nothing happened
david blaine's back there
don't even ask questions anymore like
look how neat this looks it's just like
a small little little tiny screen take
selfies easily hold up your palm where
the camera can see it to automatically
take a selfie
all right well it did it
so since i did just get this and this is
basically just an unboxing and kind of a
first look i'm going to be doing a full
review on this so if there's anything
else that you guys want to know
or want me to test out please leave that
in the comments below i'm very excited
about the future of foldable devices and
i think samsung has been doing a really
great job of kind of pushing that
initiative forward make sure you guys
are subscribed and you hit the bell so
you'll be alerted when i do my full
review video of this i'll be doing some
photo and video tests and if there's
anything else you guys would like me to
try out with this
be sure to leave them in the comments
below with that i'll see you guys in the
next video